a lot of you have been asking us to
debunk health fads so we went to LA to
meet our friend grace Helbig and try
some of the weirdest wellness trends and
search for the world's healthiest drink
up first is she logic used in
traditional Indian medicine studies show
that the main active ingredient folic
acid can help with Alzheimer's disease
and it may also help with kidney stones
but some of the claims can't quite be
backed up like it gives you better
memory mood or sharp intelligence all
right some people call this way of rocks
cause it like decomposes into rocks
basically in many ways is like eating
soil with compost basically all of these
claims have no significant evidence to
back them up and on the flip side it can
actually cause toxicity because they
found heavy metal ions in them and in
some cases traces of mercury and arsenic
there's 30 bets Oh
oh that's nice this is like straight-up
yes so this is popularized by Gwyneth
Paltrow's
have you heard of that essentially it's
like a supplement so it just has random
nutrients and chemicals in it you
aligned with the cosmic flow of great
achievement but I think they just put
the meta sound smart researchers have
found that the photosynthetic pigment
and III live does have antioxidant and
anti-inflammatory properties this is
very similar to dark leafy greens like
spinach which are really rich in
antioxidants III live is a bacteria and
though it itself is not toxic it has
been found to have toxic strains within
it some of these toxins can actually be
deadly and wild animals and people and
also it has been linked to increased
tumors and mice and liver cancer
you want to see three live
in this there is activated silicon what
do you think the hunt even though
silicon brings up images of plastic
surgery or nanotechnology this chemical
element is found in several of our foods
and fluids and is related to good bone
health but since it is found in so many
foods including cereals bananas beer and
even the water we drink no human has
ever reported a silicon deficiency
bladder description yeah and it says
these statements have not been evaluated
by evaluated by the FDA these products
are not intended to treat diagnose cure
or prevent any disease but anti-cancer
because you can get away with claiming
whatever you want as long as you have
that disclaimer on the back somewhere
you can say like this will make you
never die so while we were in LA we
actually did get our hands on what is
allegedly the world's healthiest drink
and got to try it this amazing beverage
brings oxygen and nutrients to the cells
of your body helps regulate body
temperature cushions joints regulates
your metabolism and gets rid of waste in
the body search for the healthiest drink
in the world thank you so much hopefully
you feel extremely healthy / maybe we're
gonna die
/ and this was so necessary so thank you
guys so much you don't know what
[Music]